what is the role of speaking how
important is speaking how can we improve
our ability to speak
and the reason I'm talking about it is
that you know wherever I go if I speak
to people about language learning
whether it was uh the group that I met
up with in Poland one of the
participants was a teacher who said that
her students are afraid to speak and
this lady was saying that she had French
in school and she understands but she's
so afraid to speak it just doesn't come
out whenever she tries to speak she
fails uh and I get these comments all
the time people saying that you know I
understand I can read and but I just
can't speak and you know
the first thing is obviously to speak
well you have to speak a lot so if
people are intimidated and reluctant to
speak they will never improve their
ability to speak